[Music]  turning a tragedy into an extraordinary  tribute  six-year-old maria jose gonzalez vasquez  passed away  suddenly in december of 2017 after  contracting meningitis  just months later her family and teacher  channeled their grief into an amazing  gift  they created a special scholarship in  her name tonight friends and family held  a charity golf tournament at the desert  pines golf club  it was all to raise funds for the maria  jose gonzalez fosquez scholarship  a lot of our students are in financial  need and  don't often have the opportunity to go  to college simply because of the cost  and they rely on scholarships  just to have a chance to earn a higher  education so it's critically important  to our former students  the scholarship has helped many gregson  elementary school students  achieve their dreams through higher  education for more information about the  scholarship or to make a donation  yourself  we have a link on our website  8newsnow.com